hey there welcome back millions of
people are getting a surprises tax
season smaller refunds or no refund at
all under the new tax law eighty percent
of Americans are expected to pay less
taxes overall but nearly three out of
four people in a new CBS News poll say
the new law has pushed their bill higher
or left it unchanged only about a
quarter say they believe their taxes had
actually declined we visited a family we
first met in 2017 that expected money
back and instead had to pay up we were
getting to the point where you know I
wasn't dreading doing my taxes anymore
because Jason and Amber Edwards were
counting on lower taxes and maybe even a
refund in 2018 I was a bit optimistic
the college educators from Rhode Island
had planned to put the extra money
toward their newly adopted baby son
but when they filed their returns they
got a surprise no refund and the IRS
said they owed thousands in additional
taxes it became a huge shock because we
had just started to get all the
necessities for a baby and then to turn
around and suddenly have to write a
$3,000 check
you know this was not the year for us to
be doing that they're a good example of
reality jeffrey levine is a certified
public accountant in new york back in
2017 we asked him to review the edwards
tax returns and project their tax bill
under the new law levine estimated a
savings of about six hundred and fifty
dollars and the segment was so popular
with GOP lawmakers even the president
retweeted it so what happened they owe a
lot more than they probably thought they
would have given that increase in income
because they experienced withholding
changes like most of the American public
tax withholding is the money your
employer pulls automatically from your
paycheck and sense to the IRS under the
new tax law the withholding changed
giving people more money in each
paycheck but resulting in potentially
larger bills at the end of the year like
what happened to the Edwards I know a
lot of people in this position where
they thought you know they were going to
get
and you know their paychecks were a
little bit more but then they also wind
up owing to well then why did we even do
it
for people who got a surprise tax bill
this year the vine says there's only one
way to avoid it you need to put more
money in throughout the year whether
that's changing your withholdings to
have more taken out of each paycheck or
perhaps paying estimated tax payments
that's up to you but it's pay me now or
pay me later but you're gonna pay one
way or another pay one way or the other
we reached out to the other two families
and our 2017 tax story but didn't hear
back nationally by the way refunds are
down some six billion dollars compared
to last year and 1.6 million fewer
people are getting them major there is a
major political communication problem
when you give 80 percent right tax bill
and 80 percent of people don't feel it
because they don't explain doesn't show
up when they expected that refund time
and even knows what withholding is and
people aren't meeting with their
accountant all throughout the year and
getting tax advice they go at the end
they expect a refund if it's not there
they think something's wrong yeah and so
you know an elite company I've never had
the president read one of my stories
well you know if you if you have it was
just like that out there to major
but hey Tony the fact that the other two
families didn't get back to you don't
you think if it was good news they would
have gotten back to you and you just
think it's just one of those things I
think is one of those things I don't
think they're rolling in a pile of new
tax money right now I don't think they
probably also got a shock because
everybody experiences changing the
withholding tables right and look the
administration wanted to make sure the
tax cut reached taxpayers as rapidly as
possible how do you do that you push
that through the IRS system and
withholding early then it shows up a tax
on something tells me the president's
going to retweet one of your stories
rather than like maybe this one